Speaker 1: Sadly, we start today with a tale
of stochastic terrorism perpetrated by the
twice indicted, twice impeached, failed former
president. You know the guy I'm talking about
the guy who's orange. Trump posted Barack Obama's
address or what he believed to be Barack Obama's
addressed or what was supposedly Barack Obama's
address. And even though it wasn't, an armed man
showed up and prosecutors now know all about it.
The Associated Press reports Trump posted what he
said was Obama's address. An armed man was soon
arrested there. And the question I have for you,
as we read through this is did Trump know exactly
what he was doing? Former President Donald Trump
posted on his social media platform what he
claimed was the home address of former President
Barack Obama. On the same day a man with guns in
his van was arrested near the property. Federal
prosecutors said Wednesday, revealing new details
about the case. The individual is a 37 year old
tailor, Taranto, who prosecutors say participated
in the January six riots on January six,
2021. He kept two firearms and hundreds of rounds
of ammunition inside a van he drove across country
and had been living in, according to the
Justice Department motion that seeks to
keep him behind bars. On the day of his June
29 arrest, prosecutors said Taranto reposted a
truth social post from Trump containing what Trump
claimed was Barack Obama's home address. In a post
on Telegram, Taranto wrote, quote, We got these
losers surrounded. See you in hell. Podesta's and
Obama's. That's a reference to John Podesta, who
chaired Hillary's 2016 campaign. Taranto also told
followers on his YouTube livestream he was looking
to get a, quote, good angle on a shot. Good angle
on a shot. Federal defender representing
Taranto did not immediately return a phone
message seeking comment, but a motion seeking
to have him released pending trial. The lawyer
wrote that in emotion. The lawyer wrote Taranto
is not a flight risk and he served in Iraq. Okay.
All right. So does Trump know exactly what he's
doing when he does this sort of thing? I believe
that the term stochastic terrorism applies here.
Stochastic terrorism is a technical term that is
the epitome of what we are seeing here. When
we say stochastic terrorism, what we mean is
when public figures or media outlets, sometimes
it will be Fox News or others. They can inspire
seemingly random acts of violence by spreading
hateful or extremist messages to a large enough
audience that is likely to be receptive to it. And
it is historically outside of any legal liability.
So I'll give you an example. In fact, we have
real life examples. This guy, Glenn Beck,
right wing nut, I think he has a show now on The
Blaze or one of these right wing online things.
He used to be a Fox News host, used to be a CNN
host. For a while, he would rant and rave about
an organization called the Tides Foundation and
he would say, it's just a horrible organization.
I don't even remember at this point. It's been so
long what it was that was so bad about the Tides
Foundation. But he would rant and ran and ran. He
never directed any particular person to go and do
anything to the Tides Foundation. But given that
the audience of Glenn Beck, Beck was a right wing,
conspiratorially minded audience, receptive to
having their attention focused on whatever the
scapegoat of the day or of the week was, you could
sort of predict in some general sense that Glenn
Beck's relentless focus on the Tides Foundation
might inspire an act of violence against the
Tides Foundation. You couldn't predict that.
You know, Joe Schmo, the third from Florida,
would be the guy to do the act of violence.
But you could say we know that some percentage
of the population is suggestible in this way.
And we know that Glenn Beck's audience is big
enough where if it's even only 0.1% of his
audience that would hear him talk about the
Tides Foundation and go and do something, that
means there's at least a handful of people who
would go and do it. And eventually this story
ended less tragically than it could have ended,
which was California Highway Patrol. I again, the
details elude me, but pulled over a guy with guns
in his car going to the Tides Foundation because
Glenn Beck had talked about it. That's the cast
stick terrorism. It's not that Glenn Beck directed
in the way that you might say, okay, you're my
accomplice for this crime. Go and do this thing.
I'm legally liable. Okay. I tell you to do it,
give you the means, give you the reasoning or
the inspiration. It's not legal liability. So
we use the term stochastic terrorism. That's
what we're dealing here with. Trump putting out
what he claimed was Barack Obama's home
address. You know, I used to think that
Trump winning the 2016 election was one of
the biggest disasters in American history. I
don't know that I've given it enough credit. It's
probably more like in modern world history, the
election of Trump and the cult status of Trump as
a leader to at least tens of millions of people.
Quite frankly, probably one of the worst events,
one of the biggest disasters in modern world
history. And interestingly enough, Trump wants
more people out protesting for him. Fortunately,
it doesn't seem that many people are willing.
And that's what I want to talk about next.